oh
[Musique]
maintenant il ya des gens des mots
classe qui me parlait même pas qui ne
considérons pas que je suis dans la même
classe que on existe on est des humains
on a les sentiments ça fait mal
ça fait mal c'est malheureusement un
scénario qui se répète aux états unis la
mort d'un homme noir pendant son
interpellation par des policiers blancs
lorsque vous vous attend dès maintenant
la mort de john floyd un afro-américain
activée par un policier blanc lors de
son arrestation aux états unis en mai
dernier a donné naissance mouvement de
protestation mondiale contre le racisme
et la brutalité policière
on pouvait entendre le slogan black
light bearer résonné dans plusieurs
villes canadiennes et les appels au
calme se multiplient genou à terre des
policiers ont marqué leur soutien aux
manifestants contre le racisme
après ce tragique incident mais même si
des messages d'appui à la communauté
noire ont afflué des quatre coins du
globe des disparités et des barrières
additionnel persiste encore aujourd'hui
pour les jeunes adolescents notamment
chez plusieurs francophones d'edmundston
l'été dernier j'avais essuyé plusieurs
refus sans raison apparente selon elle
alors qu'elle cherchait un travail
d'étudiant il est dit
est ce que mon concept et j'aurai une
opportunité ci a probablement dit on ne
lâche pas c'est la même réponse tu
restais selon l entreprise a pourtant
accepté de prendre le cv d'une de ses
amies blanche des situations comme
celles-ci ne sont pas isolés selon cet
expert
parfois il peut y avoir une procédure
par exemple dans l' embauche qui se
veulent neutre mais cette neutralité ne
se traduit pas par exemple dans les
pratiques
laetitia elle a ressenti un sentiment
d'isolement à l'école lorsqu'elle est
arrivée au canada en 2018
et même trois ans plus tard un léger
malaise persiste
ça prend du temps de s'habituer et que
les autres s'habitue à te voir à te
parler tout ça il faut comme société
s'assurer que les politiques publiques
que l'on met en place prennent en compte
la réalité de ces jeunes
pourquoi de rajustement interpellé les
jeunes eux mêmes
il y a urgence d'agir il faut agir
maintenant
tout le monde peut pas à déconsidérer
coin en considération ainsi que m on
parle sensibilisation une personne seule
personne toutes les races et qu'il soit
blanc noir ou autre chose
ce sont tous les mêmes
si la mort de jack floyd laisse un goût
amer dans cette lutte de la communauté
noire pour les droits civiques
alors à rappeler au monde entier que
l'harmonie se retrouvent souvent dans
les contrastes
ici daniel quatre jours radio canada
edmonton
[Musique]